[Music]
no kids for music star Jason Mraz oh
he's not yet but he does seem to have it
all so the name of his song as Jonathan
I found out when she was invited
exclusively inside his home this place
has a special name the Moran ranch do
you feel like you have it all
I do really absolutely I get overwhelmed
Jason invited et exclusively to the
epicenter of his world it's a sprawling
creative compound outside San Diego
which has a fully operational avocado
farm he also shot part of his new music
video might as well dance on the farm
which includes scenes from his 2015
wedding
track is off his first album in four
years called know during our day on the
farm Jason performs an intimate concert
a private show will be included in a
film about making his new album have it
all the movie hits theaters tomorrow for
one night only and it's a movie kind of
about one song and then also how that
one songs music video was made through a
collaborative experience with two
nonprofits in Richmond Virginia which
was my hometown
[Music]
[Applause]